you're watching the daily climate show
on sky news
on today's programme how sucking carbon
dioxide out of the air
could help the uk reach net zero
space might be the final frontier but
will it cost us the earth to get there
we hear if sustainable rocket fuel could
be the answer
and the 10 year old campaigning to ban
plastic
toys in children's magazines
[Music]
hello and welcome to the uk's only daily
climate news show where we track the
changes happening to our world right now
and meet those coming up with the
solutions and some of those solutions
will be put to the test as part of a
major new trial
looking at different ways to remove
carbon dioxide from the air
now experts will study data from five
projects testing the most effective ways
to remove the greenhouse gas from the
atmosphere well in a moment i'll be
speaking to professor cameron hepburn
from the university of oxford
who's coordinating the trial but first
what is
carbon capture
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
well let's bring in cameron hepburn
director and professor of environmental
economics at the university of oxford
hello to you tell us why these trials
are important why do we need carbon
capture they they are really important
and i'm sure a lot of your listeners are
thinking we don't want to be sucking co2
out of the air we want to not be putting
it up there
in the first place and in a sense
they're right the first priority is to
stop
our emissions but these trials are
important because if we're gonna
stop warming above one and a half
degrees in addition to going as fast as
possible
stopping our emissions we've actually
got to work out the cheapest the most
effective the most
socially attractive ways of sucking co2
out of the air as well and storing it
safely either
in land or even under underground so we
need these trials to work out
what we should do not just in the uk to
meet our own net zero targets
but globally but is there a concern that
if carbon captures
improved companies will just employ that
rather than cutting back on their
emissions
no i mean that shouldn't be a concern in
the sense that we don't have the space
to not cut back on our emissions as i
say and
we have to go full speed ahead on
cutting our emissions
and even if we do that you know because
we've left it so late to take action on
climate change
we're going to have to do this as well
so these are not choices this is the
most important thing to get across and
apart from anything else there's only so
much land on which you can plant trees
or peak land that you can restore so
we just we have to stop putting it up
there in the first place
and on top of that it's kind of stupid
to be plowing
vast amounts of money into a fossil
system to put all this co2 up into the
atmosphere
and then to spend a lot of money taking
it back down again so so best not put it
up there in the first place but
as i say we're going to have too much up
there we've got to find ways of taking
it back down
and how confident are you that we'll
have viable and inexpensive carbon
capture options
in the near future that's exactly what
this trial is about we're trying to work
out
which of these methods that they look
very attractive that's why they've been
funded that's why we're exploring them
they look as though they could be
pretty cheap in many instances and they
could work with the grain of agriculture
with the grain of nature they could
increase
productivity uh they could be beneficial
for farmers and for landowners but
we've got to test these things out we've
got to make sure that you know they do
actually work that they're monitored
properly that local people
like them the the the technologies are
advancing at the
types of speeds that we need so there's
a lot of kind of ifs and buts and
that's why we need this study and if it
does work out that some or
you know at least one of these processes
works and we want to scale it up
um globally in a way that's obviously
sensitive to
the needs of different people in
different geographies
professor cameron hepburn thanks very
much indeed
my pleasure thanks anna and you can hear
more
about how innovative technology can help
us fight climate change in this week's
episode of climate cast
which you can listen to wherever you get
your podcast from
in today's other climate news ofgem says
it's investing 300 million pounds to
expand the uk's electric vehicle
charging network the energy regulator
said the funding will go towards more
than 200
low-carbon projects to help the uk
prepare for more electric transport
1750 charging points will be installed
in towns and cities
across the country
[Applause]
the government's being warned the uk
will struggle to reach its climate
targets unless
more power is given to local leaders the
mayor of greater manchester and metro
mayor of liverpool are amongst those
who've written to boris johnson
calling for faster action to protect the
environment
they say local authorities should be
given the money and resources
to make the changes needed to meet the
net zero targets
[Applause]
the environment agency will use low
carbon concrete for flood defenses as
part of a plan to become greener
more than half of the organization's co2
emissions come from the construction of
flood defenses
it estimates the movable to low carbon
concrete could help reduce them by up to
45 percent
one of leed's most popular cycling
routes has been resurfaced using
recycled waste material volvo has teamed
up with plastic road company mcreeba
and leed city council to improve the
journey for cyclists traveling from the
city centre to the yorkshire dales
potholes along harrogate road have been
filled in using
850 kilograms of recycled plastic waste
that's the equivalent of 170 000
supermarket carrier bags
and a blossom garden is opening in east
london that's dedicated to the people
who've died of coronavirus
33 blossom trees one for each of the
city's boroughs
have been planted inside the queen
elizabeth olympic park in stratford
it's part of a wider campaign to bring
nature to cities and give more people
access
to green spaces
now it's not only what we do on our
planet which makes a difference to
climate change
today the government announced plans to
allow satellite and rocket launches
from commercial space ports in the uk
space exploration allows scientists to
better understand everything from
extreme weather to global warming
water cycles and air quality but getting
there
has a significant environmental impact
launching a spaceship into orbit is
thought to emit nearly as much carbon
dioxide equivalent
as five return transatlantic flights
but rocket launches are still rare so
that figure doesn't compare to the
more than a billion tonnes of carbon
dioxide produced each year by the
aviation industry
the bigger problem is the damage done to
the atmosphere itself
by rocket launches and it's not just
carbon dioxide that's the issue
burning rocket fuel deposits chemicals
including chlorine
into the atmosphere now chlorine
destroys the ozone molecules that
shields the planet
from the sun's rays black carbon and
aluminium oxide are also
deposited now the soot particles absorb
sunlight and heat up the air around it
and the aluminium oxide particles
reflect heat away
so together these two effects make the
surface of the planet
cooler but keep the atmosphere warmer
and as the upper atmosphere warms up the
chemical reactions that deplete the
ozone layer
happen even faster well joining me now
is sasha dairy founder and chief
executive of blue shift
aerospace who've developed a new
sustainable rocket fuel
uh welcome to you so rocket launchers as
we saw there clearly have a
a big environmental impact but how
helpful can
space exploration be in learning about
the impacts of climate change
well certainly small satellites are
being used even today
to examine the earth's atmosphere and
effects of global climate
change uh and as you all know our fuel
is one that is
very close to net carbon zero and
not all fuels and not all rocket engines
including our own emit the same
chemicals that you referred to for
instance ours
does not emit chlorine or uh or aluminum
particles with monoxide
but there you know certainly it's very
difficult to admit uh
not emit things like carbon uh as you go
up
as you punch through the atmosphere so i
think you know
rocket companies have got to look at
ways of becoming more and more
responsible and we're doing our best to
get there and aside from fuel what else
can be done to
to minimize the environmental impact
well you know i think there you know
there's things about how you burn your
rocket engines how
how cleanly you burn them how much soot
comes off of them you mentioned uh
early on about the emission of carbon uh
particles and i think that that depends
a lot on how the engine's burned
so a lot of rocket companies include
including our own
need to tweak our engines to be sure
that we emit very little in the way of
actual soot and it's a very clean burn
this actually optimizes our engine and
benefit for us
the other things you can do is look at
you know what you are doing for launches
looking for ways to offset the
the carbon production that you have
whether it's planting trees
or incentivizing your customers to
also ensure that they're using
propellants and green methodologies for
their research and their launch launch
of their satellites
sasha derry really interesting to hear
thanks very much indeed
thank you very much anna now earlier
this year
waitrose promised to stop selling
children's magazines containing
disposable toys for inspiration
ten-year-old skye neville who's
campaigning to ban plastic toys from
kids publications
in the latest of our climate diaries
skye explains what inspired her to take
a stand
hi my name is skye and i'm 10 years old
i live in a beautiful
sedona national park in north wales and
my interests are
rock climbing
[Music]
my campaign started when i started
subscribing to magazines
some magazines came in a paper envelope
unwrapped or in a potato starch bag
all environmentally friendly but some
came with like this a
plastic wrapper plastic blister
packaging
and free gifts like a squishy eyeball
so i wrote to the publishers and they
responded back was not a great response
so i started a petition online and
shared on social media
[Music]
ten days later waitrose has stopped
selling
comics with plastic toys on the front
i hope all retailers can do the same and
then the publishers
realize this is not acceptable anymore
there is no planet b
[Music]
well that's everything from us for today
coming up next time we're looking at
biomass and whether it should really be
classed as a renewable energy source
you can find out more here on the daily
climate show the same time tomorrow
thanks for watching
see you then